[Musica]
ho avuto la fortuna in gioventù per
motivi familiari perché le fortuna di
solito sono sempre quelle per nascita di
poter vivere alcuni anni in California
da Romano è stata e da italiano degli
anni della ventenne negli anni 90
ovviamente è stata una illuminazione
vedere come si muoveva il futuro no con
poter godere di una macchina del tempo
Dopodiché ho fatto una scelta
consapevole che è stata quella di
tornare in Italia Ma come dicono gli
americani con avendo preso il bug avendo
preso il virus
dell'Innovazione dell'imprenditoria
innovativa e quindi decidendo tornando
in Italia di applicare tutto quello che
avevo visto là ma rendendomi conto di
quanto fosse molto diversa l'Italia di
quegli anni dal punto di vista
dell'accoglienza dell'Innovazione dalla
visione dell'imprenditoria del supporto
del sostegno di tutto quello che era il
sistema intorno all'imprenditoria il
sistema paese ho cominciato anche ad
impegnarmi immediatamente corrente e
cercare da una parte di fare i miei
interessi come imprenditori innovativo
dall'altra nel cercare di spingere con
molti altri a cambiare il sistema perché
tutto questo perché in realtà cambiare
il sistema è un modo per generare un
impatto positivo oltre che per potersi
facilitare il percorso individualmente
Quindi io sicuramente diciamo cerco di
anche di divulgare in momenti come
questo perché sia importante fare start
up Perché fare start up sicuramente
migliora anche a me stesso il terreno di
gioco e il modo in cui io posso fare
l'imprenditore innovativo nella
tecnologia
rimanendo basato in Italia anziché
emigrare come molti altri fanno Ma fare
start up ha un impatto pazzesco che
molti non comprendono molti
sottovalutano tutti quelli che si
chiedono Ma perché mi devo interessare
delle startup del venture Capital Di
fatto sono delle avventure di individui
che decidono di rischiare dico di no di
vivere di vivere sul filo del rasoio e
sono cose in cui investono soggetti che
tendono a rischiare molti soldi che
vantaggio ne ho perché mi dovrebbe
interessare beh allora per fare questo
vi faccio vi porto indietro di qualche
centinaio di anni a quella che è stata
riconosciuta come effettivamente la
prima startup innovativa della storia
dell'umanità e cioè l'avventura di
Cristoforo Colombo che si fece
finanziare dal primo venture capitalist
della storia che era la regina Isabella
d'Aragona per fare qualche cosa di
completamente nuovo fino a quel momento
cioè tentare di raggiungere le Indie che
lui intendeva fossero il catai no la
Cina dell'epoca il gecipango il Giappone
dell'epoca per una rotta completamente
nuova per conseguire un vantaggio enorme
Perché Perché all'epoca la Cina con cui
si commerciava veniva
attraverso la via della seta via terra
quindi c'erano dei costi e dei tempi di
spostamento per commerciare con la Cina
che erano incredibili Beh L'innovazione
di Cristoforo Colombo non generò valore
solo per se stesso e per la regina
Isabella d'Aragona in realtà cambiò le
sorti del mondo della civiltà
occidentale fino ad oggi perché perché
la scoperta dell'America era
colonizzazione delle Americhe poi di
fatto ha creato tutte le premesse per la
società occidentale in cui viviamo per
il le democrazie in cui viviamo e anche
poi direttamente per la Spagna per la
ricchezza di cui ha goduto la Spagna
come è stato coloniale per diversi
secoli quindi
sostenere Le startup è qualche cosa di
profondamente rilevante per ogni società
ed è un qualche cosa che è profondamente
sottovalutato banalizzato e in alcuni
paesi in realtà addirittura svilito
sminui to come se fosse un gioco per
ragazzi e questo purtroppo spesso e
volentieri il caso dell'Italia dove c'è
una cultura d'impresa che è anche molto
molto differente direi in certi casi
avverta rispetto a quello che è il
modello delle startup
Le startup Ovviamente facendo un salto
di 500 anni avanti e ci insegnano che in
realtà prosperano
Le startup prosperano quindi come ho
detto prima quando
si sviluppano all'interno di un
ecosistema favorevole un luogo in cui
vadano ad interagire con tanti altri
organismi con l'ambiente circostante
traendone valore traendo un'energia e
quindi diciamo respirando un ambiente
che gli dia la spinta iniziale e poi le
spinte successive per riuscire ad andare
al successo auspicabilmente al successo
Perché poi sappiamo bene che la maggior
parte delle startup non ce la fanno ma
in realtà come all'interno di un
ecosistema anche quelle che non ce la
fanno in realtà tornano ad arricchire
l'ecosistema stesso a dargli un valore
come humus come elementi secondari non è
detto che debbano diventare i pesci più
grandi del Lago
gli ecosistemi il primo ecosistema della
storia che si sia sviluppato
spontaneamente poi per sostenere Le
startup sappiamo tutti che ormai è La
leggendaria Silicon Valley ma a metà
degli anni 90 ci sono stati gli
israeliani che hanno cercato di capire
per quale motivo in Silicon Valley
succedessero tutte queste cose che non
succedevano in altri luoghi e hanno
studiato e hanno decodificato il modo in
cui effettivamente
funzionava l'ecosistema questo Cluster
questo di grande distretto di
innovazione che era la baiarea la zona
intorno a San Francisco e hanno mappato
cinque elementi fondamentali Cinque
Colonne portanti degli ecosistemi e
tanto l'hanno mappati bene che sono
riusciti a duplicarli Israele ormai è
nota in tutto il mondo con una startup
nation in realtà poi dopo copiando
Israele sono nati gli ecosistemi di
innovazione di Londra di Berlino di
Parigi l'Italia stessa sta tentando di
copiare
questo modello decodificato da quello
che è stato lo studio degli israeliani e
gli ingredienti fondamentali queste
colonne degli ecosistemi startup che le
supportano fondamentalmente sono cinque
sono il talento la cultura la densità
l'accesso ai capitali e la cornice
legale parlando partendo dall'ultimo
punto la cornice legale per quanto noi
crediamo che l'Italia sia un posto con
una giurisprudenza una burocrazia
avversa l'impresa in realtà non siamo un
luogo più avverso all'impresa di spagna
Germania Francia Israele stessa cioè
luoghi dove comunque Le startup
innovative riescono a fiorire riescono
avere successo e riescono a diventare
anche molto grandi quindi siamo un po'
noi realtà che ci flagelliamo da soli a
pensare che le cose siano
particolarmente avverse in realtà non
sono più complesse che altrove l'accesso
ai capitali è un punto che può più
legato alla cultura perché in realtà i
capitali in aria ci sono cioè Per quanto
poi pure qui parliamo tanto di crisi di
economia che non cresce di
redditi bassi l'Italia è un paese ricco
siamo il secondo paese al mondo per
reddito pro capite dopo il Giappone
quindi la ricchezza privata di questo
paese cioè ed enorme e in realtà non
vede l'ora di trovare opportunità di
valorizzazione attraverso l'investimento
la densità Ecco questo è un punto
importante Siamo il paese dei campanili
tendiamo a disperdere un po' tutto
quindi il fatto che quando si è
cominciato nel 2010 a parlare di
ecosistema startup in Italia in realtà
un po' tutti hanno cercato di crearsi
l'ecosistemino sotto casa in realtà ha
rallentato molto molto la costruzione
del sistema Se si fosse deciso
dall'inizio di accentrare tutto in un
unico luogo gli investitori gli
acceleratori gli incubatori i fondi di
Adventure Capital creando un Big Bang
magari oggi avremmo Tanti luoghi molto
più ricchi e molto più di valore Perché
saremmo partiti da una concentrazione
per poi far capire tante altre località
secondarie come è successo negli Stati
Uniti dove non è che tutto il Silicon
Valle ormai i distretti gli ecosistemi
di innovazione negli Stati Uniti sono
decine dopo che la Silicon Valley si è
sviluppata tanto da diventare abbastanza
grande da gemmare nuovi ecosistemi il
talento ne siamo ricchissimi Non ne
parliamo lo diciamo lo leggiamo su tutti
i giorni su tutti i giornali e sportiamo
cervelli esportiamo laureati brillanti
esportiamo gente che ha voglia di
lavorare vanno all'estero vanno in
luoghi più favorevoli per lavorare delle
volte per fare o molto spesso per fare i
fondatori di startup in ecosistemi più
favorevoli il nostro grandissimo buco e
la cultura proprio perché noi abbiamo
una cultura avversa per molti elementi
intorno a quello che è il modello delle
startup quello che sono la nostra
cultura dell'impresa è quella della
impresa padronale della piccola impresa
del piccolo e bello del creare che
diminuisce anche da da quella che era la
cultura contadina di un tempo l'economia
agricola dei piccoli Orti avvezza quelle
che sono stati i grandi le grandi
industrializzazioni e i grandi
latifondisti quindi noi arriviamo da una
cultura che ci tramandiamo
generazionalmente che in realtà va
abbastanza contro e proprio affrontare
con un po' di pillole oggi quali sono le
frizioni principali cioè le credenze
sbagliate intorno al modello delle
startup e delventure investing quindi
come si costruisce un'impresa che può
diventare un gigante che può diventare
non voglio dire la nuova scoperta
dell'America ma la prossima Google la
prossima meta la prossima Apple la
prossima Tesla la prossima per un
esempio moderne recenti e biondtek che è
l'azienda sviluppato la startup
biotecnologica che in Germania ha reso
possibile i vaccini a mrna che ci hanno
portato fuori dalla tragedia della
pandemia era una startup esattamente
come quelle digitali
bisogna andare a comprendere Quali sono
gli elementi su cui ci sono delle
convinzioni Generali quello che si
chiama il commonland che sono opposte a
quello che è il modello delle Startup
La prima è una startup non parte da
un'idea non è non esiste il concetto del
ho avuto un'idea geniale cerco solo chi
mi dia un sacco di soldi per assumere la
gente a realizzarla è una leggenda
metropolitana Questa è una credenza
profondamente sbagliata non esistono
idee geniali esistono eccellenti
esecuzioni le idee sono una commodity
sono qualche cosa di comune sto avendo
un'idea io che probabilmente sta avendo
sta avendo altre mille persone nello
stesso momento nel mondo e probabilmente
altre 100.000 hanno avute in passato il
punto essere in grado di realizzarle le
idee Perché i capitali arrivano
progressivamente attraverso step passi
successivi e crescenti di un piano di
realizzazione di quell'idea
trasformandola in valore attraverso il
talento attraverso il lavoro quindi è
fondamentale non esistono idee geniali
che vengono coperte di soldi neanche in
si
un elemento centrale come devo essere
una startup e non è una nuova impresa
non è una nuova azienda non è un'azienda
che cresce e deve fare utili è
un'azienda che deve avere una nuova
azienda o un progetto di azienda che
deve avere tutti questi elementi ma ne
devi avere uno di cui non si parla mai
perlomeno in Italia che è la scalabilità
la scalabilità significa che il modello
di business il modo in cui si sta
creando valore in cui si sta creando
marginalità cresce in modo più che
proporzionale via via che si allarga sul
mercato Quindi significa che i ricavi
della propria azienda crescono molto di
più di quanto crescono i costi le
aziende normali tradizionali a cui siamo
abituati noi sono definiti aziende
lineari perché è vero che possono
crescere possono crescere tantissimo Un
ristorante può diventare una catena di
ristoranti e aprirne mille nel mondo è
un'azienda che cresce non sarà mai
un'azienda che attirerà capitale il
rischio professionale perché il capitale
di rischio che quello che detta le
regole su cosa è una startup e come
possa arrivare veramente al successo
attraverso i cari vari gradi di
finanziamento si basa sulla scalabilità
del modello di business Cioè più si va
avanti più si investe più si raggiunge
mercato più il margine di profitto il
rapporto tra i ricavi e i costi è
crescente il venture Capital non
finanzia aziende lineari finanzia solo
ed esclusivamente aziende scalabili
Quindi questo è un errore comune io ne
sento continuamente io faccio
l'imprenditore ma faccio anche
l'investitore mi arriva in continuazione
gente che mi propone progetti che chiama
di startup Ma che sono solo delle degli
avvisi azienda ma di azienda
tradizionale lineare non sono scalabili
quindi non sono investibili perché il
rapporto di possibile ricavo del mio
investimento il rapporto a rischio che
io vado a sostenere
sostenibile gli investitori
professionali investono in cose che sono
Si rischiose ma in cui se va bene perché
una su 100 ce la fa per citare una
canzone
in quel caso mi restituiscono un
multiplo tale che mi recuperi far
recuperare anche tutte quelle in cui ho
investito che sono andate male un altro
elemento che molto su cui molti
sbagliano in Italia è quello del
business plan spesso fuorviati dai
consulenti in silenzio erroneamente che
il punto di partenza di una startup sia
scrivere un business plan e a quel punto
andare a cercare montagne di soldi per
finanziare il passo d'impresa Come ho
detto prima una startup parte da piccoli
passi di esecuzione fa un passo in
avanti osserva su come sta innovando
osserva dove è arrivata osserva in quali
condizioni ci è arrivata Cerca i soldi
per fare Il passo successivo fa Il passo
successivo Cerca i soldi per fare ancora
quello successivo quindi sono degli
andamenti anche raccolta di investimenti
crescenti si fanno i round preferenze e
family Quindi o ci si autofinanzia nella
primissima fase per provare a fare
qualche analisi di mercato poi si va a
fare i round che si viene detto del
preside con cui si parla con i primi
investitori professionali che spesso
sono gli acceleratori e si prende
qualche decina di migliaia di euro
qualche decina di migliaia di euro che
serve per fare un Concept per
intervistare un'ampia audience di
mercato di utenti per capire se
comprerebbero una volta che si faccia il
prodotto Quando si verifica che ci sono
tanti utenti che comprerebbero il
prodotto o il servizio si passa al round
Sid che cominciano ad essere centinaia
di migliaia di euro di investimento con
investitori che cominciano a diventare i
primi piccoli fondi che sono dedicati
alle fasi Sid con quei soldi si fa un
prototipo e si fa davvero sul mercato e
si verifica Se tutte le proprie ipotesi
Sul modello di business funzionano solo
a quel punto si arriva al Fami
utilizzato venture Capital che non è mai
il primo investitore in realtà è
l'investitore di quarto livello perché
prima si deve verificare che ci sia un
team una delle competenze in grado di
realizzare L'azienda si deve verificare
che ci sia un mercato che comprerebbe un
servizio si deve verificare che c'è il
per un prototipo sia stato in grado di
fare un prototipo e che c'è gente che lo
compra e c'è un modello di business
sostenibile Allora si è arrivato al
venture Capital perché manca solo la
benzina per cominciare a fare un
progetto di crescita di questa impresa
un'altra credenza sbagliatissima di
questo paese No il modello del piccolo
imprenditore che era con la con il
vecchio adagio che le società si fanno
in un numero di soci minore di 2 dispari
per dire che non bisogna avere soci Le
startup hanno sono geneticamente delle
società non padronali non esiste il
socio di maggioranza sono delle squadre
sono dei Team sono delle competenze che
si mettono insieme sono condivise dal
primo momento non l'uomo solo al comando
esistono talenti che si mettono insieme
si mette insieme un tecnico un marketer
Un economista hanno insieme tutte le
competenze per tentare di fare una cosa
mai fatta prima ma non è neanche poi
così lineare perché poi in realtà
andando avanti si imbarcano altre
persone si imbarcano altri Talenti si
imbarcano i primi dipendenti si
imbarcano gli investitori quindi la
realtà è che alla fine di un progetto di
startup anche se anche va a successo in
realtà i fondatori tipicamente forse ne
possiedono ancora il 20% dell'azienda
perché tutto il resto l'hanno condiviso
con gli investitori con i consiglieri
con i dipendenti si dice Silicon Valley
che la vera missione del CEO
dell'amministratore delegato di una
startup è rendere ricca la segretaria
che sta al desk dell'ingresso perché il
piano di stock Option deve far sì che
chiunque stia lavorando in quell'azienda
sia partecipe del successo dell'azienda
Perché solo così che delle imprese
riescono ad arrivare veramente al
successo ed è vero che non tutte
arrivano al successo Come ho detto prima
una su 100 ce la fa è anche vero però
che quando si arriva a quella una su 100
qui va sfatato un altro mito la startup
non è un'azienda che ci si tiene per la
vita salvo rarissime occasioni in cui si
diventa degli out performance in cui si
performer in cui si diventa appunto
Facebook e ci si ruota in borsa perché
Perché cominciare a tirare a bordo degli
investitori professionali significa fare
un patto dal primo minuto e che gli si
consentirà a un certo punto del percorso
arrivati al successo di vendere tutto
quanto perché loro si devono riprendere
i soldi che hanno investito moltiplicato
tante volte quindi quando si riesce a
potarsi in borsa perché sei diventato il
leader del mercato mondiale in cui sia
entrati magari i fondatori rimangono
anche nell'azionariato e continuano a
gestire l'azienda ma è un'eccezione
tipicamente la fine del progetto del
percorso di una startup è quello di una
cessione a tutti una cessione di tutto
da gran parte di tutti ma questo
continua ad essere un grande valore
Perché i fondatori di startup sono dei
soggetti che non solo dopo aver avuto
anche il successo ci riprovano o quelli
che hanno avuto insuccesso ci riprovano
ma soprattutto diventano i soggetti che
investono sempre che si rimettono a
rimettere a rimettere insieme i pezzi
dell'esperienza che sta che è terminata
che è andata in cocci sia che sia andata
bene sia che sia andata male e provano a
reincollarli in un altro modo per
generare nuovo valore e il più delle
volte si rimettono a generare questo
nuovo valore reinvestendo dal territorio
da cui sono partiti quindi in qualunque
territorio viviate sostenete i vostri
imprenditori e sostenere Le vostre
Startup
[Musica]